hello thing
are you as into Wednesday's severed
companion thing as we are we are
absolutely obsessed with Victor
dorobansu's stellar and completely
practical performance did you know they
had to make holes in the floor sometimes
to hide him thing is a classic character
in The Addams Family Canon number one it
was important to camouflage the rest of
him thing was played by magician Victor
dorobansu they specifically wanted a
magician for the role but more on that
later the first phone call I had with
with Tim he wanted thing to be derived
from an actor a performer Victor was
covered head to toe in a blue suit and
was often hidden behind Corners
underneath objects and most often behind
Jenna Ortega while filming actual
filming process was um just like working
with another actor he even had the
luxury of being wheeled on a camera
Dolly alongside her number two remember
when thing helped Enid and Wednesday win
the pokeup he played a major part in
their Victory by decking Kent in the
face before he could destroy their boat
there were no special effects involved
just Victor underwater holding his
breath and posing for the camera check
out how the scene was shot it's pretty
impressive how he managed to do so many
takes underwater without coming up for
air action freeze it go and action
one more quick number three not like
anything we've mentioned so far would be
considered easy oh yeah paint out it's
easy but we're like painting out 90 of
the human being that's dominating the
shot keeping the rest of him the hand is
actually a major challenge it's a slow
setup as they have to make sure the set
is lit well enough so that Victor isn't
casting any Shadows or anything that
could take away from thing looking like
anything other than a severed hand
number four yes hours for one hand the
prosthetic and makeup application that
Victor had to endure was no easy feat
the makeup artist spent hours applying
the stitching blending and coloring in
the subtle purple tones that could
easily be overlooked and we both know
how vain you are number five Jenna
Ortega describes the filming process as
working with a regular actor you're um
reacting and he's speaking he's signing
Victor had to develop the particular way
that thing would essentially speak to
the other characters years it's pretty
hard to find movements that can express
feelings Jenna had no issue while
talking to a hand with Janna she
accepted it really quickly that she's
talking to her hand the only part she
struggled with was when she had to
pretend he was there when he really
wasn't did you really think my highly
trained old factory sense wouldn't pick
up on the faint whiff of Neroli and
Bergamot in your favorite hand lotion
number six they specifically needed a
magician's hand for the role in the 90s
thing was played by a fellow magician
Christopher Hart they wanted to continue
with that type of casting for Wednesday
somebody who had the right look to the
hands who had Nimble fingers was able to
do all these moves naturally a magician
would be the right choice for the role
also they had to be you know young
enough and supple enough to fit in very
awkward situations number seven a lot
had to be done to accommodate the rest
of Victor's body we mentioned before how
he had to be hidden sometimes it wasn't
so easy hey I can't fit under a bed
let's make a hole in the floor if you
think that sounds excessive
let's raise the whole building in the
air so put him under the floor sometimes
times when all else failed they had to
break out the CGI number eight this is
where it would get a bit tedious on set
you have to prepare with the VFX guys
find ways to hide the thing if you've
seen our other Wednesday videos you know
how long Jenna Ortega's work hours were
this was part of the reason for that
every single setup we did someone would
have to come in with a gray ball silver
ball chip chart this inevitably slowed
things down a lot there's a lot that
goes into doing it number nine the way
thing communicates with Wednesday was
premeditated by the iconic Duo not only
that but it was made up on the spot
before shooting each day every day we'd
show up and go ah that looks right I
feel like I kind of know what he's
saying I know I'm stubborn single-minded
and obsessive number 10 did you know
this was Victor's first acting credit
Victor is a magician by trade that's
what he does that's how he makes his
living he's never been an actor being on
a set like this was all super new to him
him it's pretty hard to create from
start to end when they first brought him
in for rehearsals everyone was impressed
by how quickly he nailed the character
particularly things signature walk at
first scene he kind of really nailed
so what do you think about Victor
dorbonsu's first on-screen performance
after being hidden underneath the floor
wielded
we're impressed what was your favorite
thing moment